ma la disamina o se siamo ritornati
perché parlo di we are back to consider
cosa sarà ricordata ragazzi quel
giochino canino dove devi essere
premuroso nei confronti di quello che
succede
io lo fui tanto alla consideriamo e
vediamo se riusciamo continui e fuori
della stessa perché c'è il tasto
continua 51
allora eravamo rimasti che solo fare mi
piacciono i pelati a devo guardare non
si guarda la tipa non si guarda le
ragazze m sì gentleman guarda i pelati
che sono anche gli sconti per ragazzi
numero 52 non avesse sono vicino la
tizia direi italia e ci guardano tutti
io amo questo gioco ha spesi 5 euro
migliori della mia vita
sfida che è veloce questo invece è un
atto da gentlemen big blind soandri
micro est di un software ghost e leg
competition finance day
droid droid chu young non ha capito
niente
non ho capito niente film che fa ero io
basta corte tris
[Musica]
io io non potevo non fare questo è
perché lo facciamo test e la personalità
di nuovo e ho capito altre fi alte f4 al
34 c'è un capello 58 questo sono io
come potete vedere alziamo il volume
ragazzi a senti questa canzone sono i
rammstein e il loro prezzo sia
auslaender bellissimo regalo
bisogna far capire la gente bisogna far
ascoltare una città propria musica
sono di questo parere oggi è il premium
friday io sono il boss oggi ed essere si
va via alle 15 state a casa voi brutti
schiavi di ma sono i 17 vorreste andare
a guardar netflix bet sente numero 60 ci
sono un deficiente
oggi il nostro livello perfetto esco con
un cavallo era ora sushi o gli occhi in
cui che credo che sia carne di cavallo
amore stasera cannibali e trulli mair le
considera it con che il giappone non ho
mai sentito nessuno che ascoltava musica
in pubblico
mai mai r è un fantasy sushi c'è un gal
da gallina li acquistò questo sono io
veramente non appartenete al sushi i
piatti girano quindi tu prendi quello
che preferisci io questo sono io a su
chico e quelli con comuni con rullo
questo sono abraham ed io quindi non sto
facendo una cosa che non fare nella
realtà sono esattamente io perfetto gli
altri tornano a casa a digiuno
fantastico i say that play piovan
largo anche nello scorso episodio della
star of six in free o devo aspettare che
non devo prendere qualcosa c'è gente in
coda
ti va di ballare la sagra la samba
voglio uno strawberry dai funghi no
pezzente non volevo farti passare porca
vacca perché così gentile
[Applauso]
[Musica]
frate cagare non mi alzerò le mani love
to the world che kringe non li sta
neanche seguendo la ragazza triste
d'europa formi e ho fatto così appena
detto global warming sa di cosa parliamo
sexy e sex attacchi sono io mi piace un
sacco la c'è un posto del potrei non dar
fastidio agli altri ma sai che faccio
gofas tv a tutti è certo perché altri
devono essere più agevolati no diamo
fastidio a tutti sexy age è successo
aiuto oh mio dio alleato sparo i miei
amici non sono uscito uccidere mio amico
non sono uscito a cedere niente io
osservo le situazioni lol sixtynine
screening questo film era una merda 70
a demoni volevo prender lavoro non sono
uscito va beh almeno arrivato da te
volevo togliere lo non son riuscito
perché non ho schiacciato il tempo bella
chissà quelli che stanno dietro di me al
cinema che esperienza di manager 6 20
giu oddio che è successo non c'è cibo e
nel nostro la nostra pentola quello che
arrivò arriverà quello che chiediamo
rivela presto arriverà assolutamente
niente mi serve per diventare un gigante
[Musica]
ragazzi chiedetevi essere ha coordinato
1 scordinato come come pochi quindi di
che cosa stiamo parlando
sarei è molto molto peggio nella vita
reale quindi figuriamo è sempre stato il
mio sogno farmi salvare da un principe
del sul suo cavallo bianco e allora vai
alla corsa dei cavalli
di sicuro non andare al castello
malvagio e utile a salvare nessuno dei
ragazzi qua ci si diverte bellissimo
prof.sa prova a seguire il trend per una
volta non mi è riuscito neanche così
bene impegnando quindi figuriamoci a
devo censurarla ok sorry ecco a posto da
me è il cibo ain e forse solare perché
facebook mi scrivi a devo devo tirare
non devo beccare la palla perché devo
farla passare come se una professionista
però fai schifo stata bravissima non
sono che sos che è stata proprio brava
lei
[Musica]
che figata posso ficcarmi nell'angolo ha
detto qua eccolo tactical nuke i clown
here i am the top a siamo quasi arrivati
in cima
ciao rocchi ei ragazzi sono molto
confuso però mi piace fare questa cosa
per dargli fastidio 84 c'è un orso
facciamo finta di niente
avg di morto non so fingersi morto
ammazzami textbook che cosa che guardo
lei quella ti sia appoggiata sulla
faccia ma no scherzavo guardiamo del
posto che c'è un tizio con le guance
enormi perfetto insomma non aver
considera il con l'orso incazzatissimo
la cintura tesoro ma dovresti mettere e
mettila nel mio naso
ecco nella mia ho anzi meglio secondo me
a sistemi di ritenuta siamo a posto poi
se ci ferma la pula non soffre questo di
spender qualcuno conosce la risposta
ovviamente tu che in realtà non la sai
poi solo finta questo e come vi
considerano tutti i professori ragazzi o
anche se alzi la mano e notare di
sposarlo a chiedere a te non capisco
perché guarda sto gioco ma non vedo
nessuna pallina non è il gioco nel tempo
si annuncia le palline ma scusatemi
c'è un ufo oddio oddio prendi la coppia
parola volevo farmi fare della posta
loro
oddio che è successo a aprì la finestra
non me ne frega niente tipo sta
soffrendo ok ora è già adesso ti puoi
vedere se è di chi uomo finestra
vabbè fa niente avrei aperto solo un
pochettino considerei 96 ragazzi gli
ultimi quattro oggi avrò sicuramente un
po 5 cedermi e quindi sono annoiato devo
attaccare un pianeta qualcosa del genere
un eroe e via un eroe cenno dove c'è
l'eroe ovviamente perché almeno c'è un
po di combattimento e mie mi tengo
occupato sono che noi a 98 ecco l'eroe
era meglio l'altro di pianeta prova
niente
[Musica]
e passato un po di tempo cucchia mista
ma sei arrivato
[Musica]
volevo veramente vederti quindi è finito
il gioco in realtà
tieni soltanto la mia mano riporta
indietro di ricordi vero sei anche
andata a questa è la mia prima ragazza
miss ha saltato l'appuntamento con una
mucca anche con un cavallo una volta
sarebbe stato più bello rimanere con te
per più tempo
ti ricordi quel mostro gigante lo
sconfitto totalmente e ricordi il primo
giorno in cui ci siamo incontrati non
voglio morire schiacciato il tasto mori
area dove piazzare il logo del di chi
l'ha fatto di chi ha fatto il gioco
l'agi mode corporation l'anno fatti non
l'ha fatto nessuno questo gioco ai
risultati finali
[Musica]
cosa vuol dire consider it un gioco
fantastico per 5 euro meraviglioso
secondo me
fatemi sapere cosa ne pensate iscriviti
al canale se volete altri video leggere
e schiacciate il tasto mi piace per
farmelo capire e noi come sempre ci
vediamo ad un prossimo video bella
ragazza
[Musica]